voilà on arrive on est prêts regarder
les regarder comme elle est fraîche
celle ci allait là oh là là regardez la
louche d'or merci c'est le cas ni sexy
et derrière c'est le printemps et les
fleurs à ses correspondants
on adore autant vous dire que vous avez
vu elles sont au taquet je sais que
l'émission va être violent
j'en ai un qui se perd dans votre foi
dans ce bar je regarde bien c'était vrai
qu'ils s'étaient jamais un parti annahda
et les à vous êtes responsable d'une
s'attache à bordeaux oui est ce que vous
faites de taffetas je vends des bûches
envoie pour noël donc dans le paquet de
la sciure de bois aussi pour vraiment
rappeler le côté naturel à ouidah rime
donc l'été où il n'avait jamais testé on
sait pas comment elle décliné pour les
payant peut-être dans des
les corps des décorations dans les
supermarchés tête et nous on s'est dit
mort lorsqu'il est à vienne
bon ben ce terme mesdames et messieurs
l'homme vivait au bio il est chaud mais
les gros oméga goût mais l'époux merci
fort saint-andré guen bien j'aime bien
c'est important
[Rires]
le litchi c'est celui ci alors voilà
si vous aimez le blog
l'homme à la journée mettre le public de
touche m'en passer son affiche de
l'année dans leur folie
salut salut et la bassée haisnes pas
d'ambiance et les amis es
la saga
[Applaudissements]
alors on peignait là où est ce qu'on va
nous retrouver maintenant sur s'est vite
et c'est maintenant l'heure volontat
[Musique]
il court il court le furet le furet du
bois joli
allez
[Musique]
de retour avec bonheur
bien
[Musique]